اذا مشاهدينا نبدا الخامسه من تداعيات
تصريحات الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بان
بلاده ستنشر اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه في
بيلاروسيا المجاوره في خطوه اعتبرها حلفاء
كييف واعتبرتها انها ستزيد من منسوب
التوتر الدولي الذي نجم عن اندلاع الحرب
في اوكرانيا فقط وصف حلف الناتو تهديدات
روسيا النوويه بالخطيره وغير المسؤوله قال
ان التصريحات عن دور الحلف باي تصعيد هي
تصريحات وصفها بالمضلله النيتو اكد انه
متيقظ ويراقب تهديدات موسكو النوويه عن
كثب كما قال انه لم يسجل اي تغييرات في
موقف روسيا النووي تدفع الحلف للتحرك
وايضا تعديل وضعه النووي
كيف من جانبها لم تنتظر كثيرا للرد على
تصريحات بوتين حيث دعت اوكرانيا الى
اجتماع طارق لمجلس الامن التابع للامم
المتحده قالت الخارجيه الاوكرانيه في بيان
انها تتوقع اجراءات فعاله من المملكه
المتحده والصين والولايات المتحده وفرنسا
لمواجهه ما وصفته بالابتزاز النووي من
الكرملين
الرجاء ايضا من برلين التي انتقدت عبر
وزاره الخارجيه اعلام بوتين وضع الاسلحه
النوويه في بيلاروسيا وقالت انها محاوله
اخرى للترهيب النووي الخارجيه الالمانيه
اضافت ان مقارنه الرئيس بوتين قراره
بسياسه الناتو النوويه هي مقارنه مضلله
ولا يمكن ان تبرر الخطوه التي اعلنتها
روسيا